if you walked into a club people are
gonna be afraid and turned on I grew up
in a very conservative Asian household
so my mom used to associate tattoos with
pretty much all the stereotypes you can
think of that you see in the media I was
always taught to believe that tattoos
are only men for gangs and dropouts
certain places like hot springs and gyms
outright ban people with tattoos I was
never the rebellious type but I was
always obsessed with tattoos tattoos are
more accepting now today but I wonder if
there's a line that's gonna be crossed
if I have a neck or face tattoo I just
want to know what it feels like to be
fully covered
I'm either gonna look really bad azz or
look like a wannabe hipster II can't get
over the fact that how real these look
so the first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
going to call my mom
see how she thinks so my mom in
particular hates my three tattoos that I
have so I couldn't imagine what she was
gonna say when she saw my neck tattoo my
mom yeah it's real you don't like it so
yeah she hated it
not surprising she outright banned me
from coming home that's the family love
for yeah it's not real its fake
they want you out there that's all look
at you some of my co-workers were just
intimidated by my new look you look like
you could beat me up you're walking down
the street I think the neck tattoos are
the biggest contributing factor to the
intimidating you look like they do zip
if I were going to attack your caller ID
like I want him okay your mom is gonna
kill you others were really into it yeah
I think it works though I think you
should do this for real
I mean I'm feeling this sleep I feel
like you should just have this look on
the air do not watch this you just fine
look good you look like fine it's all a
99 and some people are just straight-up
confused what's going on why it's just
that these don't feel like you know I do
you look badass yeah you I mean you look
totally normal in Los Angeles I remember
when you had tattoos you're like a dog
gangster back in the day now it's just
art so overall my co-workers seem to
like it but the true test was definitely
going out into the public with my new
tattoos I'm about to walk through the
store and see if I can get any reactions
from strangers for me I'm already
self-conscious about my own body so
having all these tattoos on me really
made me self aware it's really really
nerve-wracking because I don't know
whether they're looking at me because it
looks weird on me or because it's just I
don't know because I have to me tattoos
and it's just weird
in general later that night we decided
to go out for drinks and you know at
that point I just probably forgot that
they were all me a lot of people are
staring but in a good way
Wow no didn't feel uncomfortable anymore
and I was having a good time it took me
a second when I first came up I was like
wow drastic but I can take Ken as this
from now on until you wouldn't judge me
no no no Lenny we could pull off tattoos
it to you at the end of the day you
should never judge a book by it's cover
whether it's one or twenty tattoos
that's your body and you get to choose
what you want to put on it if I'd
knowing you knowing you if you did this
real life I'd be wondering like what
kind of crisis you're going through I'd
wonder what can I be doing to help
[Music]